[Music]
today we want to talk about cloud DevOps
right so you talk about DevOps most
people think this which is it's a great
way to connect the development and
operations teams and bridge the gap yes
this is true but DevOps is a lot more
than just that ultimately what DevOps
can do is get your business more agility
and can bring feedback from all of the
downstream systems including your
customers back into the development
process so that you can build great
solutions for your customers so as we
think about cloud DevOps at Google
there's three principles that we keep in
mind the first of course is how do we
increase developer productivity because
that's what we're all here for the
second bit which is just as important is
getting all of that downstream feedback
and shifting it left so developers have
access to it earlier in the cycle what
this lets you do is avoid those costly
mistakes and catch them much much sooner
and the third piece which is just as
important is cailed operations what the
cloud lets you do is run your business
at scale and cloud DevOps should enable
that so we're going to talk a little bit
about each of these three aspects and
then dive into a fireside chat as well
and a little bit of time so first let's
talk about how we increase developer
productivity as we talk to our customers
the number one thing we're hearing from
them is yes they've looked at cloud as a
way to lower their costs but they want a
lot more than just that they want
greater agility for their business and
the way they want to do this is by
building cloud native applications
there's been a huge surge of interest in
this especially around kubernetes
unfortunately though
active teams across a number of our
customers are still working on
traditional ideas that are optimized for
local app development those run on
premise and one of the challenges with
this is as you use these local
environments to build cloud native
applications you frequently end up with
either more complexity or errors that
are caught too late in the cycle so to
solve this problem we announced cloud
code yesterday and what cloud code lets
you do is rapidly build debug and of
course to apply these kubernetes
applications and the best part is you
can do all of that right within the
context of your local development
environment so think of this is a power
boost to your IDE and we've shifted left
all of the complexity and we've
abstracted it away so you can actually
just focus on building cloud native apps
so tell you more about this I want to
welcome on stage just humble who's part
of our developer advocacy team just
[Music]
so how many people in this room are
building codes in nodes or NGO or Java
or Python okay that's a lot of you great
and how many people know how to setup
and manage a cube in a t's cluster okay
that's all so a lot of you that's great
how many of you are going to be working
on kubernetes in the next year okay
almost everyone so that's great
kubernetes is the industry standard
infrastructure for building cloud native
apps but if you're anything like me you
might find kuna T's a little bit
intimidating to set up and manage you
might also worry about the impact on
your productivity my favorite experience
as a developer is being able to hit save
in the IDE switch to the browser hit
refresh and be able to see pretty much
instantly what I did so that I can check
that I'm on the right track micro
services and service-oriented
architectures also add complexity and we
want to create a simple way for you to
stand up some subset of your production
environment for development purposes
locally so today we're going to show you
cloud code cloud code lets you develop
codes in vs code and IntelliJ and get a
seamless near-instant developer
experience that mimics what you're used
to that local developer workflow so to
show you that we're going to build and
deploy a simple distributed system this
is a guestbook which is going to talk to
a micro service that does translation of
the comments and the guestbook into
different languages we're going to start
off by building and deploying the
translation micro services and then the
rank here is going to show us what that
looks like in Java using IntelliJ thanks
guys thanks everyone for coming everyone
here is sort of terms like continuous
delivery continuous integration
continuous deployment today I'm gonna be
showing how to use cloud code for
IntelliJ to set up a continuous
development loop where I can edit and
save my code locally and it's going to
get deployed and running inside of a
cloud kubernetes cluster inside of
google kubernetes engine so right here
we have a cloud native guestbook
application it's a very simple hello
world service it
was written in Java and is printed out
hello world over HTTP we can see that
this is running in our continuous
development loop so it's running here
inside of remote kubernetes cluster in
GAE refresh see that we get have the
message I'm gonna come in here and
change this message and press save and
this is where the continuous development
loop kicks in so we can see here below
the cloud code is watching this code for
changes detected that I saved this file
and starts to automatically rebuild
repackage and redeploy this up to gke
so this code is turned into a container
using our fast container builder called
jib which knows how to optimally rebuild
and repackage a java application and get
it running in a container registry
alright so it should just be about to
finish up here and we can refresh and
see our new message so we're able to
make this simple edit and you get it
running in gke very quickly this is the
basic app though this isn't the
translation back-end that Judge talked
about before so to turn this into a
translation back-end I'm going to first
add some client libraries and enable
some API is so that we can use the
Google Cloud translation API and I do
this using another feature of cloud code
they come in here and add cloud
libraries and manage cloudy pies I'll
click that this is the translation
back-end so I'm going to click here on
Cloud translation and there's a feature
here to automatically enable the API
mgcp for us so we don't have to leave
the IDE I'll click continue and this
next dialogue is a way to have cloud
code automatically create a service
account and secret so that you can talk
to this API since we're running in
google kubernetes engine though we don't
need to use this I'll click OK and now
cloud code is automatically added this
dependency to our application added it
to our pom dot XML and started to
rebuild and repackage just again for us
I'm going to switch this code out for
translation back-end can elect its
redeployed I'll explain how this works
here's the main function here it takes
in some strings over JSON on the HTTP
and first passes them to the translation
API to detect the incoming language and
the X based on what language it is we
translate this to both English and
German and then at the bottom here we do
some debug log into system dot out all
so this looks like it's about finished
and we can try it out here so I have
some text save that we're going to send
it as a translation it's a couple
strings so a couple strings
faster one in English hello world and a
sentence in German we can see that these
are both translated back into English
and German and the final cool feature is
that cloud code automatically stream to
these large from gke back down to our
IDE so we don't need to go anywhere else
to see the debug logging so not only did
it deploy into kubernetes without you
having to do anything it also streamed
the logs back into the IDE for you and
and that would have been hard to do when
you're writing this great stuff awesome
so we got this simple translation back
and running now we're gonna look at how
to use this in a bigger distributed
application
thanks very much done whoo yeah live
demoing is terrifying
so obviously in a real system we're
going to have more than one service
interacting so now we've got our
translation micro service life we're
gonna build this guestbook and and
deploy the guestbook which is written in
no js' and Vijay Subaru money is going
to show us how to do that using BS code
take it away Vijay hi this is the thanks
Jess this is the guestbook application
that jess was mentioning where users can
add guestbook entries in a language of
their choice and will go ahead and
integrate this with the translation
service that Dan has built to display
English and German translations for
these messages and I'll be using the
cloud code plug-in for various code and
I'll go through one cycle of the inner
development loop make four quick code
changes deploy them to the remote
cluster and troubleshoot if required so
the first change I'll make it in the
display template to add some style
sheets that are required next I'll go
and add some placeholders for the
English and German translations then
we'll go to the app the J's file and
tell it that it can find the location of
our translation service from the
kubernetes environment variable then
we'll add the main logic to call the
translation service for each of the
guestbook entries it's a straightforward
loop will add some error handling as
well and then finally we'll publish the
location of our translation endpoint and
then we'll go ahead and save our changes
and the continuous deployment has been
monitoring you for your changes and once
it's detected them it's packaged them
and sent it over to the remote cluster
for deployment and as as you can see the
deployment has already finished and
let's reload this so there you go we
have our English and German translations
that does not look like German does it
just nine does it Nick the deutsche
structure okay
so let's go see what's happening so the
logs that were in the remote cluster or
stream directly back into your IDE so
you don't have to go around hunting for
them so from the logs we can see that
German messages are indeed coming back
from the translation service so that
service communication is working fine so
must be something going on with our
application so why don't we just try to
debug let's set a breakpoint here and
let's start our debugger and the
debugger attaches against the running
process in the remote cluster so let's
go ahead and reload our application boom
the debugger breakpoint has been hit and
we didn't have to do anything this is
against a remote cluster that's amazing
so we're debugging using the regular IDE
debugger in the Kiba Nettie's cluster we
didn't have to you know create any
launch configurations right any llamo do
any port forwarding it just worked from
within the IDE that's awesome stuff
and and this is a fully-featured
debugger you saw me stepping through it
you have the watch variables you've got
the hovers you can even inspect the
variables so from this I can look at the
temporary translations array that the
code is building and I can see that the
German translation is reaching my
application code so maybe we're missing
some kind of assignment statement
somewhere so let's go ahead to our debug
console and hardwire one of these
assignments and see if it gets reflected
in our application so we hard-wired for
one of the end entries so and let's
delete our debugger run through and
there we see the entry that we changed
is being reflected in our application
and once again not changing the state of
the live system from within the debugger
a cool stuff so looks like we're missing
an assignment statement somewhere there
it is so let's go ahead and fix it and
let's save our changes and stop the
debugger and trout code would have
picked up these changes and would have
already started packaging them and
started deploying to the remote cluster
and as soon as it finishes deployment we
can reload the page
it should obviously the idea takes its
time especially when there's a demo
that's a built-in feature if you're
demoing it adds a special lag just to
make your life difficult
so it'll it'll reload the page with the
right entries so what you just saw was
one cycle of the inner development loop
we made some changes
we'd applied them we debug them and you
don't have to touch any communities
configurations yourself crowd code
handled all that for you in the
background
cool thanks very much BJ okay so once
you've got your service live in
production obviously you have a whole
team that takes care of it and Ben is
going to be talking about SRE
later on in this segment so one of the
key concepts of sre is a fellow's or
service level objectives and these are
targets for the health of your
application that represents something a
user would experience not a proxy
variable like CPU usage or memory usage
and once we have SL O's what happens is
our application breaks them and we get
woken up at 4 o'clock in the morning so
I've been woken up at 4 o'clock in the
morning because our application has
fallen below its SL O's and I'm going to
ping Christie Wilson who is on call for
this app and she's gonna work out what's
going on so that we can remediate and
get everything working again over to
Christie all right so it's 4 a.m. I'm on
call and I've been paged I need to
figure out what's going wrong in
production and fix it as quickly as
possible
so to do that I'm going to use cloud
service mesh or CSM so CSM is currently
in alpha and it requires Sto but
out-of-the-box I can take a look at
things about my running services like
the metrics I can look at the logs and I
can look at other telemetry data as well
and I can create my own custom SL O's so
here we can see that I've already
defined one for 95th percentile latency
and it's being violated and since I'm
looking at the front end service I have
a pretty good guess that the reason I
was paged is because the front end
service is overloaded so I need to
mitigate this as fast as possible so I
can get back to bed so to do that I'm
going to use
cloud code so cloud code can be used by
all kinds of engineers whether you're
wearing your developer hat or your
operations hat and so what I'm going to
do is I'm actually going to take a look
directly at the production cluster in
the cluster Explorer now obviously not
all developers should have access to
this but I'm on call so I do so in the
cluster Explorer I can start looking at
what's going on in production I can see
my deployments they're all green and I
can start diving into individual pods I
can look at the containers in those pods
and I can see details like what
environment variables they're running
with what the status is and I can even
get the logs from my production cluster
right in my IDE and if I want to I can
even connect a terminal and start
executing commands in my production
containers so one thing that I'm
noticing is I look at this is that our
overloaded service only has one replica
running and since it's overloaded I'm
thinking maybe a way I can work around
this is to increase the number of
replicas so to do that I'm going to use
this edit icon here and I'm actually
going to bring up the production
configuration right in my IDE and make a
change so I want to increase the number
of replicas from 1 to 10 but I'm tired
so I made a typo and I put the value in
wrong but fortunately the IDE has my
back so it's telling me because it's
aware of the schema that the type is
wrong here and this should be an integer
so I can make the change I meant to and
because it is aware of the schema the
IDE can give me intellisense and show me
what values are valid at this point in
the configuration so let's go ahead and
save that and the IDE prompts me to warn
me that it's about to apply this live to
a production cluster which yes I did
want to do and in the cluster Explorer I
can refresh and I can see that
kubernetes is automatic immediately
doing what it does best and scaling out
the ten replicas that I requested so any
ops people sres for sis admins are
probably having a mild heart attack at
the moment watching Christi changed the
state of a live production cluster from
her IDE and in fairness that wasn't a
feature we had originally planned we got
feedback
from our early access users that they
wanted this functionality and in
fairness it's super useful if you're
managing a dev cluster or a test cluster
it's really really helpful however in
real life what we want to do is make
this change to version control push it
out through a deployment pipeline this
is the paradigm known as infrastructure
as codes or get ops so Kristi how do we
do that well let's take a look at the
files in version control so this is the
deployment in version control and as you
can see because of my emergency change
it has fallen out of sync with
production so I'm going to make the
change here but before I do that I can
show you some other cloud code features
if you've been working with kubernetes
you've probably noticed that you end up
dealing with a lot of gamal but having
the amyl support directly in your IDE
you can make that a lot less painful for
example if I'm looking at this [ __ ]
deployment and say I want to know what
the value is of this secret instead of
having to dig around in the yamo in my
repo and figure out where that secret
lives I can actually just peek at it
directly and see what the value is and
these base64 encoded strings I can just
hover over them and see what the
plaintext values are I just want to
emphasize Kristi did not choose that
path but never do that I'm gonna have
some words with some people after this I
think so what I'm going to do now is
open the configuration and make the
change to ten replicas so now I would
commit this push it and open a pull
request and then cloud build would kick
in and it would do all the things that
we want to do to properly land this
change in production like running
vulnerability scanning tests etc thank
you so much Christine
and so this is what it would look like
in Google cloud platform in cloud bills
seeing the bills that have gone through
into prod from version control so once
we've got everything working again we're
going to go back to sleep hopefully and
get up in the morning and work out what
the actual problem was in the app that
was causing that performance degradation
we can use stack driver profiler to do
that
stack driver profiler is really powerful
some of our customers have seen double
digit reductions in CPU usage as a
result of using it and it's generally
available as of Tuesday so today we
showed you cloud code cloud code lets
you develop deploy and debug your
kubernetes based applications directly
from within your IDE and it doesn't just
work against gke it works against any
kubernetes cluster whether that's local
in a data center another cloud provider
cloud code will talk to you any
kubernetes cluster you can download the
code that we've showed you today it's
available in nodes and go in Java and in
Python start playing with that right now
we really hope you're as excited as we
are about this powerful functionality
and we cannot wait to see what you do
with it thanks very much for your time
back to you Poli
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Jess that was super exciting
to see and one of the great ways you can
increase developer productivity while
you're building cloud native kubernetes
applications so let's talk about the
next thing which is shifting left and
the purpose of shifting left as we
discussed earlier is to help connect all
of that downstream feedback to your
developers and your development teams so
you can catch those costly errors much
much sooner this could be everything
from enforcing coding guidelines to
getting operational metrics earlier in
the cycle and of course one of the most
important things you want to do is cache
those security errors very very early in
the process because those can be really
costly to tell you a little bit more
about how we're thinking about shifting
security left and give you a prediction
errs view of it I want to welcome Mike
berry from ANZ on stage
[Music]
so good morning everyone my name is Mike
and yes I work in a bank the aims at
Bank has been operating Australia for
the past 180 years and every day we look
after the details and information of
millions of customers and we look after
billions of dollars of transactions so
as you can imagine security is very
important to the way that we operate now
banking over those 180 years has changed
considerably it used to be about how
secure your vault was in your branch and
that was security but now we have on
more things to think about in particular
today we're going to talk about security
of our services and applications as
they're running in the cloud now we have
vulnerability scanning so we're going to
talk about two things the first
vulnerability scanning when you're
running vulnerability scanning the
question is how are you doing it so
today do you have in the audience here
do you have vulnerability scanning of
some kind that you're running right now
let's have a hands up yeah we have all
right we have vulnerability scanners out
here this is very good my question is
when you run these scans what do you do
with them do you go oh I've got the scan
run and now I'm going to raise a ticket
or I've got a dis report and I'll look
into that it will raise a risk or do
these things last for a day or for a few
days or sometimes you're like oh my
goodness we haven't run this for a few
weeks and now we're getting to the end
of the project
quick run a scan and see how it goes and
then oh my goodness we're going to spend
days going through these vulnerabilities
doing patching doing retesting doing
reflexes and then finally it's all
sorted out and so that kind of approach
to your security can really slow down
your work and impede your velocity so
what we're doing now the aim said is
we're using the vulnerability scanner in
Google cloud but we're using it in every
build that we do so we see here we have
our source code our source code moves
into cloud build and does all the usual
things we're doing a build but at the
same time we run that vulnerability scan
and what happens is if that
vulnerability scan fails then instantly
we have a read build and a developer can
go in have a look at that
now what is the issue and it will
highlight for you the severity it'll
highlight for you which package is
impacted by that and you can go in and
you can do the patching or remediation
whatever is required and you fix that so
you find that problem you fix that one
small problem
and then that's resolved run the build
again everything is green and everything
is fine again and so instead of taking
this huge amount of pain down the end of
weeks of your work and slowing down we
just take these little increments along
the way when you find these things as
they occur we fix them straightaway and
that helps us keep that velocity moving
as we're working in our development and
so that's one way that we're approaching
security the other one is binary
authorization so we've looked at kind of
the left side of that CI process now we
need to move on to the deployments so as
we move our deployments through how are
we doing the enforcement of this
security because you may have lots of
security applications because that's the
when we scan things with run abilities
that's one process we have but we have
lots of other security tools lots of
other test processes maybe you have
performance testing how are you
gathering that information and making
sure that it applies to that binary that
you're moving into your production
environments because if you have
security and you have lots of reports
that you leave those reports tacked up
in a big pile in your desk that's not
helping anyone what you need to do with
that information is enforce that and so
Barney authorization is a way to enforce
your security now I will talk about it a
little bit but maybe what we'll do first
is to do a little demo and have a look
at how this applies that there's no
shortage of laptops today all right so
this is a simple demo what we've got
here is my two images in my container
registry and now by looking at those
images you tell me which one has passed
all of my testing and all my criteria
and which one has not and the answer is
you can't tell just so you know but
we're gonna find out so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna grab the business
processor and we're going to deploy it
and one-button ploys
yes we're gonna hit refresh we're gonna
look at our cluster and oh my goodness
that's the wrong one so we say here is
that this is being forbidden by our
policy that says this image has not been
approved and so the way this works by
your authorization sees your image comes
in and it looks for an attachment that's
attached to this so it's a way to attach
a certificate to say this is past our
policies and we have a certificate to
prove that this image is okay with us
and in the case of this particular image
that image is not okay and it should not
be deployed to our environment now don't
worry we're not going to leave it with a
red we're gonna have a look at business
Orchestrator that's our other image you
know press a button Orchestrator they'll
press that button magic is gonna happen
yes get refresh it's a perfect demo so
green lights we want to real happy
because this image actually has that
certificate attached to it Bonni
authorization reads it it says this is
past your policies you are cleared all
the way through and you've got a big
green light for that and so the way it
works is imagine this you have a
internal audit team and they come to you
and they say we need to understand your
controls we need to understand your
policies so what we're going to do with
you is we're going to set you a meeting
for a couple of hours and we're going to
read documentation together and we're
going to understand how that your
policies work you're like well that
sounds like a lot of fun guys but how
about we do a demo I've got an image
here this image has been approved by
nobody it's been tested by nobody and
really I didn't even know where it came
from and I'm going to deploy it to
production then you jump into production
and you press the deploy button and you
show your audit team look this cannot be
deployed to production we don't just
talk about security here we enforce our
security and so we make sure these
things can move through because they are
approved now when I've done this demo I
just did that with the Winer test oh the
one policy but you can have a multitude
of policies that you may want to apply
and do that for different clusters and
depending on how you set up your
organization so imagine it in one
cluster you're like all there has to
have
here is we need a peer review that's all
we need you can deploy to this cluster
the production cluster maybe you want a
peer review maybe you want to pass the
certain phase of testing and maybe you
want to add to that that there's a team
or even a person if you choose to that
is a part of this and so if we go back
to the slides now we can see on the left
side we have a vulnerability scanning
we're testing this thing straight away
and then as they move through
deployments we're making sure that we
have just those trusted images that move
through and they're deployed to engine
and because this is all a pipeline so we
have security but it's moving through
with automation in with this fee that we
have available from this automated
pipeline and so at the end said Bank
that's how we're applying these two
principles to make sure that we move
with security and all the things that we
need but looking at security forward
with speed and reliability so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
how we can increase developer
productivity with cloud code we then
talked about shifting left especially on
security with cloud build now let's talk
about how you can scale your operations
this is one of the huge benefits of
cloud and why all of you are adopting
cloud today so if we think about scale
operations my mind goes back to Google
because we've got eight products with
over 1 billion users each and as you saw
during the keynote yesterday or shared a
study that showed that of all of the
major clouds Google cloud was the most
reliable and much of that is because we
have internally in Google an amazing SRE
team that helps us scale and operate all
of these Google products and of course
Google cloud as well and for the last 15
plus years there's been one
person at the head of that team so I'd
love to welcome on board Ben trainer
who's been leading our asari team for
the last 15 years for fireside chat
[Music]
no pressure then so then we talked about
all of these billion users services yes
I wonder how many folks in the audience
or using billion user services every day
well I suspect you know probably a few
but it's also it's one of those those
interesting myths you say well
sree isn't that for only the really
really really big services and I think
we maybe have an audience today an
opportunity to talk about that a bit but
certainly you know I started the Essery
team a little bit as you say fifteen and
a half years ago now Google was not that
big at that point and in particular some
of the services that we were running it
were actually fairly modest in size and
we've found that we have a set of
principles and practices that we can use
across services at pretty much any scale
and we found that they helped yeah so
Ben as you think about these sre
practices could you share a little bit
more about what those are yeah
absolutely and I think you have a slide
up here that talks about you know a
study that was a Forrester did recently
about SRA practices and shadows and
essentially you know can these be used
by anybody or do you need this huge
monolith of code and engineering support
they found roughly half of them did not
need this but let me talk about a few of
the essary practices that I think are
usable and applicable to pretty much
anybody who's running a service the
first is one that we talked about a bit
earlier which is having SLO s and you
know so that was a pretty dry term it
sends for a service level objective and
you know the people number people get
excited about service level objectives
is modest let me assure you but what s
ellos really mean is you want to be able
to measure what your actual end user
experience is and you want to have an
opinion about what performance would be
sufficient for most of your users to
like your product we actually internally
call them happy SL
it sounds very cheery but it's a very
simple concept right measure your
application the way your end user sees
it and have an opinion about what the
end user would need to see to be happy
sounds really easy it's actually usually
fairly hard in practice most
applications don't actually instrument
what the user sees they instrument some
things that are along the way and say
well good enough right and what we've
found in SRA and in running Google
services is actually that last mile of
instrumenting the common activities that
users are actually doing is really
important oftentimes the behavior that
they see isn't what you think and the
instrumentation that you do in
intermediate steps doesn't actually tell
you about some of the problems that
you've got and so I like the different
gyms they like there's blackbox
monitoring a blackbox monitoring is what
you're you're happy I solos eventually
should be looking at now you know as we
saw earlier if you're on call and the
monitor says something's wrong you want
a little more information than that and
so in addition to that you know you'll
clearly have SLO s for internal
microservices and in SLO its brain or
immediate steps and so on but the most
important thing is instrumenting the end
result because after all that's the only
thing your users sees and really it's
the only thing that they care about and
that's something that you can do right
away in fact really it's easier trust me
to do when the application is small then
when it gets bigger so another concept
that we use that really sort of applies
to everyone is this concept of error
budgets and an error budget sounds like
a very that is odd thing if you've read
the SRA book it probably seems less odd
but it's an important concept in site
reliability which is that our goal is
actually not perfect availability
because number one right your users are
using you know a device maybe a laptop
maybe a phone maybe a computer which is
not a hundred percent reliable they're
communicating with your service over a
network which is not a hundred percent
reliable
etc etc etc and so the difference
between let's say five nines and
is probably in not distinguishable by
your users because there are so many
other things that in the path that will
also break their experience but the
engineering cost of the difference
between five nines and perfect is
immense and it's drag on your feature
velocity is immense and ultimately you
know you're running a business you're
running a service and so these two basic
goals I want a service that's reliable
but I also want high feature velocity I
want to be able to launch new things
that my users what is really important
in error budgets is the concept that
lets you bridge those two and it's you
know it's really fairly simple if your
availability target is four nines then
your error budget is that last point oh
one percent and you can spend it on you
know silly errors right pushes that
shouldn't have been made features that
basically don't work or you can spend it
taking calculated risk right exposing a
new feature to 0.01 percent or 0.1
percent of your users for 10 minutes and
measuring the result and if you have
happiest lows you know whether it worked
or not um this lets you have very fast
feature velocity because you can take a
small risk look at its effect on your
SLO and decide whether you want to make
that a larger risk or not and it also
helps the SOE team or your operations
team agree with your development team
should we do that as well are we out of
budget
yes or no we are not out of budget let's
go ahead and launch it right we have
budget to spare and if we are out of
budget
okay data says we're not making
sufficiently prudent or careful choices
we should hold back and spend a bit more
time on availability blameless
post-mortems somebody mentioned it
earlier when I think there was a hiccup
in a demo this is a necessary practice
it's actually pretty easy for everyone
to adopt and it's it's not you know not
a complicated idea again in theory
harder to implement in practice but the
basic idea here is you've hired good
people you have a recruiting process to
identify people are intelligent and
smart well intentioned and despite all
of that right despite these people doing
their best something went wrong look at
how your system works and figure out how
you'll make it less likely for the
system to break easier for the people
who are looking after to fix it when it
breaks and make those the goals of the
post-mortem right figure out how to make
it more likely to succeed next time
despite the fact that there are going to
be people working on this who are
intelligent and well intentioned and
imperfect and then finally capping an
eliminating toil this is actually it's
better if you start this at a small
scale but this is the idea that every
system as time passes requires more and
more things that need to be done by hand
because you know we were in a rush you
needed to get that feature out the door
and there were a few goods that weren't
fully buttoned down but we can deal with
them later my experiences there is never
the later right there's only the now and
by the time you finish that feature
there will be the next round of features
that you're already slighted by and so
you know get rid of that fantasy and
instead say toil you know human work to
do something where that work does not
make tomorrow better you'll just have to
do it again toil is another budget that
you have to manage and in sre at Google
we say toil is capped at 50% you can't
have the team spending more than half of
its time on sort of non repeatable human
actions to support various you know
interesting features and snowflakes and
so on
and the rest of the time has to be spent
making the service better building
production infrastructure etc and once
you view it as a budget then you ask the
question well where am I going to spend
my toilet and it'll be on the things
that are brand new and hardware you
don't really know exactly how to do them
automatically yet and then you'll have a
fraction of your development time that's
spent
implementing and deploying projects that
get rid of toil in the places where it's
now easier and that cycle kind of
continues forever but it's important to
keep this as an explicit budget and it's
important to actually watch to make sure
your teams don't spend too much I have a
toil because there's only two options
right option number one your service is
not successful your business goes under
and none of this matters right option
two your service is successful it grows
and toil typically grows roughly
linearly with the size of your business
so if your team is
d % occupied with toil right now I'm not
doing anything fix it and your business
doubles guess what right you're gonna be
hiring a bunch more s Therese not a good
plan so this is in some way it's a plan
for success and it involves a certain
amount of continuous investment but it
absolutely is the right path if you plan
to be successful so Ben as I talk to
customers
the first thing they tell me is like
they love this concept they want to
implement all this but the water that
will take them a lot of money clasp them
a lot of money or they probably need new
people so how do you respond to that
yeah first I laugh so you know the S I
tell people I'm actually a software
engineer right this is the first
operationally oriented role I've had in
my entire career and I started out in
enterprise software interestingly at
Oracle when they were a little 400
person company who knew and you don't
actually need new people to do s re or
to do DevOps or to do these practices in
fact you should have people who are
engineers and who consider themselves
software engineers and who will be bored
to tears if you ask them to do the same
thing over and over again because they
have the right mindset to say how do I
make a machine do all of this boring
work this repetitive work this vigilance
work that people are actually quite bad
at so that I can get on to doing
something that's more interesting and
that's a great motivation these
practices then give them guidance on how
to do that effectively you definitely
don't need new tooling I mean all of the
things that we've described here like
what you have now in cloud is way better
than what we had in SRA in the early
days and in fact a number of the systems
that we have here have been influenced
by what people have discovered in DevOps
over the years and yes this isn't just
for cloud native right these same rules
of physics essentially apply to any
system I will say that services that are
running in the cloud definitely have it
easier because as you've just shown
you've built a bunch of the things into
cloud that we have
to build ourselves but the open-source
community if you're still running things
in-house the open-source community now
offers a lot of the assistance for you
as well and I would definitely take
advantage of them so as I talk to these
customers again the other common thing I
hear is hey we've already got a DevOps
team yep so do we need to now create a
second SRE team so the good news is no I
I've gotten this question a few times
over the years I feel like like when des
re back in 2004 and there wasn't have
ups at that time as well but both of
them have emerged as industry let's call
them tracks since then but SOE and
DevOps are not different SOE is a
particular instantiation of DevOps but
nothing more and if you actually go
through and read what the different
branches of DevOps have to say about how
systems should be managed how services
should be monitored etc they're very
similar to what SOE does I simply would
say sre is a more specific
implementation of this general class of
DevOps it's worked well for us it
doesn't necessarily have to be exactly
the recipe that everyone follows it's
not the only path to success but I would
say these two were very much
complementary ideas and in some places I
expect the the folks in the broader
DevOps community absolutely will come up
with a superior approach in which case
we will adopt it and we have written now
two books in the SAE team covering our
specific implementation and again I
think those are useful for folks to
understand what we did and how we did it
they don't necessarily have to be
adopted wholesale by other teams so Ben
could you actually share with with the
audience what are like a few things that
they could just start doing tomorrow
yes adopt a sorry so interestingly when
we wrote the first sre book that was one
of the principal questions we got back
is okay this this all sounds great and
these are interesting stories but but
how do I turn this into practice and so
we wrote the second book in part to
answer that question and if you have the
time and energy I definitely recommend
reading it we put very bit into it but
let me give you three that you can do
kind of today or immediately there are
three of the most important practices I
think the first is to actually write
down those happiest or those we talked
about it is perhaps unsurprising but but
still surprising how few SLO s actually
get defined and monitored and how often
what you find is what we've monitored is
the thing that's convenient versus the
thing the customer cares about and then
over a series of outages and
post-mortems you eventually migrate so
you can skip that whole step right and
go directly to to sort of the great end
result if you take the time to write
down the SLO is that if you just barely
were meeting those things most of your
customers would be happy and then dog
food them right if you use your product
internally and you should try making
your internal instance of your service
operate where it's just barely meeting
those SLO as you've just wrote and see
whether your internal users are happy
and if everyone's more or less yeah you
know seems slightly sluggish but it's
okay you've got a good SLO if everyone
grabs their torches and pitchforks who
comes to your door you may want to
revise secondly we talked about toil
toil is is it's like technical debt
right except it's much easier to measure
and my recommendation is you know look
at your sources of toil and just pick
the one that's the highest ROI right
it's easy to fix it occupies a lot of
people's time maybe because it gets done
a lot and start an engineering project
to actually fix that carve out folks
time because it gives you this great
experience of now we've spent ten months
of engineering and we've gotten rid of
any ears per year of toil okay now I see
how the system works and we can have a
regular review and sort of look for our
toil and decide which ones are worth
eliminating and that gets you started on
a path to avoid what we call ops
overload which you don't want to be in
and then finally everyone has some
production incident right whether it was
an actual full blown outage or just
something that didn't go go well conduct
a blameless post-mortem try
the approach of saying let me assume
that although humans will always make
mistakes I'm not gonna focus on that
because I don't actually know how to fix
that in the real world but I can fix how
the system works and detect the
post-mortem where the conclusions are we
should fix the following things in the
system to make it less likely to fail
more likely to provide good diagnostic
information when it does fail make the
failure less severe make the failures
shorter and see if you like that result
if my prediction as you will
[Music]
you